I Google you know we talk a lot about
Google glass
it but even before most people are on
Google glass Google contact lenses
are on the way the we've got an image
how it works I
the Google contact lens contain to
control circuit an image capture camera
component
and image sensor it can be wirelessly
linked to a mobile phone for data access
and to issue commands be audio
the system will be able to detect faces
potentially allowing
the blind to recognize people okay so
there's a lot of good stuff
the medical staff helping the blind
obviously great I'm so we talk a lot
about who s here
and I can book firm believer its gonna
completely change how we all act if your
glasses right now because they already
have
that can be able to be put in designer
glasses you're going to be recording
that imagine if I felt like I was just
gonna have to be a pretty hard for them
the Idaho it that would be very upset
that would be terrible up but
where it seems like we're already
skipping ahead like we're gonna have
Google ass for like a couple months yeah
and you know some people have it ready
but we have a couple months and then
bang
ibn contact lenses is a scary people
I always say what a beer in science when
I when I do that you're against
technology
because I want to be recorded every
second buddy I'm
split on this because the person like oh
this is super like Logans run and then
they're gonna like popped my eyeball out
when I get to a certain age it's gonna
be horrible yeah but then it's like it
unit
your area it's too late seriously go
fuck yourself I can think about the
cochlear implants all the stuff that
makes
deaf people be able to hear it if this
is that if this if this can be that for
blind people are talking about
I don't know I didn't realize so many
people having diabetes problems with
diabetes but yet they said that that to
regulate their glucose
her gonna be really helpful that's cool
but is that what this is really about
I doubt it right somehow this will
really be about poor young is about
how it all goes the poor and leads the
way with technology
I don't I'm not sold on Google glass
I've been wrong a lot of stuff I think
Intel I see something that indicate
people want to distort their faces
and right now it's a facial distortion
reacted to the way the laserdisc
it might mean stop we going with that
like to work in some
walk around heaven to touch your glasses
like there's gonna come a point
where word 28 its to upsetting into our
regular lot like
and bright now boo left looks like I get
it there's gonna be some hookah bar
maybe sometimes you want to do it yeah
well I was a kid again they're gonna
they're already making designer glasses
they are not as uprooted I don't know
but it still
you still so have that the camera people
wearing Google glass is what you know
the right Google+
right to read the story on it and like
in paragraph 9 the
what it was occluded in your list their
neighbors like every muscle
might also help the capital letters
might also help the blind see
I'm like they really buried at Lee I
will admit that I i 100 per with we
compare Primus
yeah yeah that's more important yeah
maybe
while notion thats everything ok thank
yet that actually
was second to glow Kolkata glucose yet
network that would they were invented
for to read the glucose for diabetics
think kathleen modern levels would you
let me because it can be read in the air
Directioners fascinate alright so I
think we're both saying is I should stop
being so fearful up where this all leads
or I just watched so many science
fiction movies and smoke so much on yeah
I'm
that I always see everything where the
robots come get I don't doubt that at
all
that you've done that yeah here's think
that I'm holding my phone
yeah I'm probably recording you so it's
like what
just as a public service to you yeah but
I think it's like you say I don't wanna
be recorded I don't want you know it's
making you paranoid but were already
being recorded
all the time whether you like it or not
whether you know it or not so how is the
clap our the glass any different yet
do you think we're gonna have places
ultimately I think they they've been
popping up already I think there's a bar
in Portland where people
they're banning all that but you they
were gonna have like technology free
sonya is where you're going to go to
dinner and they're not gonna literally
a cure for that yet yeah there are some
those places like they wanted to work on
all of its placement but
technology free because everybody there
is working on their screenplay written
computer chip
but I mean you can't talk on the phone
you get there can't be any noise and I
think they'll be more that I just
like 3d glasses like 3d TVs and maybe
that will take over but
and the moment the you make people watch
television or watch a movie and
worse than the put heavy glasses on for
them to put something on their face
I just think it's different I'm not I am
prepared to be wrong
but my hunch is that something will get
nowhere well that's just a small step
for that
the contact lenses and that make that
maybe the proof that
but also yep touch their I I know
there's a lot of contact lens wearers
but
Jesus how do people do that it they had
never had never won a tony award for
years now where a player
you know what I said athlete up